le malaise persiste à l'hôpital
pédiatrique Clocheville de tour la grève
entamée par le personnel soignant au
début du mois est reconduite oui les
propositions de la direction pour palier
le manque d'effectifs ne satisfont ni
les syndicats ni le collectif
Clocheville sousension à l'origine d'une
pétition qui a déjà recueilli plus de
26000 signatures on va plus loin sur ce
sujet avec notre invité bonsoir Marion
Lachot bonsoir vous êtes infirmière à
Clocheville dans le service de soins de
suite et de réadaptation vous vous
occupez d'enfants polyhandicapés alors
la direction du CU tour a donc proposé
neuf équivalents temp plein
supplémentaires pour faire face à la
crise des effectifs que vous traversez
c'est déjà ça ça de prix pourquoi ce
n'est pas suffisant selon vous euh alors
tout
d'abord donc c'est l'ensemble de
l'hôpital Clocheville donc ce que ce qui
représente 18 services qui sont en grve
depuis le 2 octobre et la Direction
annonce la création de quatre postes
donc pour nous c'est vraiment seulement
qu postes pas du tout alors quatre
postes pérenes au sein de l'équipe de
suppléance donc l'équipe qui a amené à
faire des remplacements au pied levés
des congés des congés maladie maternité
et cetera et euh et donc quatre postes
plus elle ils ont annoncé trois postes
de remplacement de longue de d'arrêt
longue maladie donc c'est des arrêts qui
durent depuis 4 ans donc aujourd'hui on
les remplace mais c'est des postes qui
sont pas du tout pérennes et deux
équivalents temps plein pour des
personnes qui sont actuellement à 80 % h
à qui on va proposer des 100 % mais en
20 % dans ces fameux ces fameuses
équipes de suppléance il faudrait
combien de postes selon vous euh selon
les syndicats c'est une soixantaine de
postes une soixantaine de postes pour
remplacer les arrêts maladies c'est ça
il y a un taux d'absentéisme vous
préférez t d'appeler taux de taux
d'arrêt de travail he c'est ça de 12 à
13 % qu'est-ce que ça dit ce cet
absentéisme ce taux d'arrêt de travail
bah en fait bah on est des humains donc
nous aussi on a des maladies nous aussi
c'est beaucoup de femmes donc il y a
beaucoup de congé maternité on s'arrête
aussi plutôt parce que bah on peut pas
aller jusqu'au enfin jusqu'au bout
enceinte euh et puis il y a aussi un
épuisement donc c'est un cercle vicieux
parce que moins on est remplacé bah plus
on va être fatigué plus on va être
fatigué plus va on va être amené à
s'arrêter plus rapidement des
burnouts voilà je pense que c'est un
épuisement généralisé et aujourd'hui on
a on tire la son d'alarme parce que
c'est les pass qui en ptissent est-ce
que la direction peut faire des miracles
on sait aujourd'hui que l'hôpital
n'attire plus si les soignants ne sont
pas là pour postuler est-ce que vous
avez la possibilité d'en recruter plus
c'est compliqué bah en fait il y a des
des des étudiants qui viennent faire des
stages il y a des gens qui postulent on
a eu vent de 10 étudiants qui n'avaient
pas été pris donc c'est pas du tout ça
ça continue à attirer après c'est sûr
que les étudiants à l'hôpital on n pas
trop le temps de les former enfin c'est
encore dans le même engrenage de la
charge de travail on n pas le temps de
les former ils sont dégoûtés parfois ils
commencent la formation ils la
poursuivent pas au bout des 3 ans à
cause de ça mais mais il y a une demande
et et ça va enfin de d'améliorer les
conditions de travail ça va
Ronner envie voilà redonner le le métier
attractif la c'est pas une perte de sens
en fait c'est enfin les gens ils ont
envie de faire ce métier il voient qu'il
y a un sens donc en fait c'est juste la
charge de travail qui n'est plus gérable
l'autre revendication c'est d'améliorer
les locaux les bâtiments he c'est ça ils
sont inadaptés et véus malgré de récent
travaux l'hôpital pédiatrique dernière
nouvelle devait bénéficier 12 millions
d'euros de travaux d'adaptation et de de
restructuration ça n'a pas eu lieu ça
n'est pas suffisant alors moi en terme
de chiffres je pourrais pas vous donner
de détails là-dessus tout ce qu'on sait
c'est que donc clogeville devait faire
partie du nouvel hôpital trousseau euh
voilà on a appris l'année dernière voilà
on a appris l'année dernière que ce ne
serait pas le cas et du coup on voit
clair
queil y a pas eu de travaux effectués et
en fait on accueille les patients dans
des conditions vraiment
déplorables cet été il y a certains
services où il faisait 32 degrés donc ce
qui est énorme quand on accueille des
petits enfants enfin des des nourrissons
par r r voilà exactement l'hiver dernier
les les les agents donnaient des des
couverture de survie pour que pour que
les enfants et chaudin c'est hallucinant
de de penser à ça quoi les ascenseurs
qui tombe en panne enfin c'est c'est pas
possible il y a un vrai danger en fait
pour pour les patients l'hiver pointe et
avec lui la maladie une maladie la
bronchiollyite alors est-ce que vous
êtes inquiet par rapport à l'arrivée de
cette potentielle maladie bah en fait on
peut pas être particulièrement plus
inquiet parce que c'est comme ça tous
les hivers enfin c'est pas une surprise
la broncoolte c'est tous les hivers donc
tous les hivers bien sûr on est inquiet
parce qu'en fait cet été on était
inquiet et et en fait il un nouveau
traitement il va pas suffire bah il est
en coné insuffisante comme beaucoup de
médicaments entre parenthèses mais pour
l'instant on nous a on nous avait dit
que tous les enfants pourraient y
accéder en fait aujourd'hui c'est les
enfants qui sortent de la maternité
enfin les bébés et moi par exemple dans
mon service où c'est des polyhandicapés
des enfants très fragiles bah ils ne
peuvent pas en bénéficier ils sont pas
dans les dans les listes prioritaires
pour avoir accès à ce médicament là
merci beaucoup Marion lâchon on rappelle
qu'une pétition est lancée sur
Change.org avec déjà plus de 26000
signatures merci beaucoup d'être venue
sur notre
plateau